I know I said in my first video that
what happened that went up today that I
wasn't gonna do four videos in a row but
I completely forgot there was a Godzilla
trailer dropping too so Godzilla king of
monsters are king of the monsters
whatever same thing so I had totally
forgotten that this trailer was dropping
I didn't do a review of the 2014 I think
it was a Godzilla film my overall feel
on it is that it is a pretty good
possibly even really good giant monster
movie but only an OK Godzilla movie
because you know it's one thing to you
know get all our teens you know talk
about the very first Godzilla film be
like he didn't show up for a long time
well yeah it was his intro film but you
look at what people love about Godzilla
in the what like 50 films he's been in
since then you want him up there and we
did have to wait a long time for that
and you know it didn't help that the
main character that we were stuck in and
that film was really bland I don't even
want to say that he was poorly acted
because I think they tried in some ways
to be consistent with what you know a
soldier in that situation would be that
he would be you know walking it down
keeping on point you know he's not going
wrong the way that these things usually
do which I mean it's it's valid as an
artistic choice unfortunate not quite as
interesting to watch but the last 10
minutes or so were pretty damn kick butt
and this what this trailer is selling
this new one is that last 10 minutes
much more which is a good thing to be
selling now I do still wonder if
godzilla himself is going to be I don't
want to say minimize but not get as much
screen time as you might otherwise think
because we actually don't even see a ton
of him in this trailer a lot of it is
giving us glimpses of all the other
monsters but boy there's a lot of other
monsters in this I I'm I probably missed
a few of them even but we've got Rodin
we've got King Ghidorah
we've got think it was Gamera like I am
that and that one I wasn't expecting I
was like wow really so that is that is
cool stuff the whole thing with you know
the voice over being like humans are the
parasite and these are the fever it's
you know your standard sort of
pretentious don't mess with nature thing
that is embedded kind of inherently in
the in the Godzilla franchise so while
it is admittedly very overwrought I'm
fine with it because it's totally
consistent with what these films are and
have always been so I I'm not even gonna
criticize it for that I will just
acknowledge that if some people found it
like too on-the-nose and too cheesy I
get it but that's Godzilla or at least
as far as I'm concerned that's Godzilla
so the we get a bit of our lead
character who I actually even looked up
her name before starting and it has now
completely been 11 from stranger things
and part of me wanted her to like hold
out her hand and like bring down Rodin
while while having a nosebleed but yeah
that's my that's now my crossover
headcanon fan fiction thing but they had
her what with what I was pretty sure was
Gamera like connecting to it I'm like
are they keeping the like Gamera friend
of children thing cuz that's like the
cheesiest part of that particular
monster and that would be awesome did do
work with that and bring that in that
would be really cool but we've got so
many monsters in this and you know we've
got and Godzilla I Godzilla when he was
actually on screen was really good in
the last Godzilla movies so I if this
film
is not overselling how much the monsters
are in it I think this could be a really
fun time it means that first of all it
needs to be under two hours like
regardless of how many monsters are now
regardless of on it really should be
under two hours but assuming it's under
two hours and we get a good distribution
across the whole thing of these monsters
that people know and love because they
realize nobody cared about their what
Mew toes which was a stupid name for the
other monsters in the first one so
seeing these things and as someone who
like I was never that deep into you know
the the older Godzilla kaiju moves I
liked them I only saw like I don't know
maybe four in their entirety and bits
and pieces of another four or five or so
but like I still I recognize these
monsters and that that gets me excited I
know that's that's a real cheap
nostalgic pop look something you
recognize get excited but you know what
if you do it right it works as long as
when we actually get to the film there's
a little bit of substance behind the hey
here's something you recognize but in
terms of a trailer no that's it that's a
legitimate way to get a pop out of an
audience and yeah that worked for me I
am certainly not pumped about this to
the cent that I was with likes a glass
but this made me more interested in a
film that I was only kind of just
shrugging and figuring I would see
because people expected me to see now I
actually kind of actively will want to
see it and I consider that a job well
done on the part of this trailer because
it up to my interest in the film
Godzilla king of the monsters what did
you think about this trailer whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do you know all the
stuff I don't need to list it I will
mention I have a patreon that's kind of
the big one but links to that and a
bunch of other stuff it's all done in
the description so take a look at that
if you care and
their case until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]